mes chers compatriotes
les événements que nous venons de vivre
sont grave
ils ont entraîné des drames humains et
des pertes matérielles considérables
la justice est saisie elle fera toute la
lumière
elle sera sans faiblesse
les procédures d'indemnisation seront
accélérées
à toutes les victimes à leur famille je
veux dire ma peine et la solidarité de
la Nation toute entière
ces événements
témoignent d'un malaise profond
certains ont provoqué des incendies dans
les quartiers même où ils habitent
ils ont brûlé les voitures de leurs
voisins de leurs proches
ils s'en sont pris à leurs écoles alors
Gina
c'est une crise de sens une crise de
repères c'est une crise d'identité
nous irons nous y répondrons en étant
ferme en étant juste en étant fidèle aux
valeurs de la France
face aux violences des dernières
semaines
face aux souffrances et aux difficultés
de temps de nos concitoyens notamment
parmi les plus vulnérables
la première nécessité
c'est de rétablir l'ordre public
j'ai donné au gouvernement les moyens
d'agir
j'ai notamment décidé de proposer au
Parlement de
projets pour une durée limitée
l'application de la loi du 3 avril 1955
ce qui s'attaquent au bien et aux
personnes
doivent savoir qu'en République on ne
viole pas la loi sans être appréhendée
poursuivi et sanctionner
et je veux rendre hommage aux forces de
l'ordre
aux policiers aux gendarmes
aux pompiers aux mers et aux élus
au magistrat
aux travailleurs sociaux
aux enseignants aux associations qui se
sont mobilisés pour ramener le calme et
la tranquillité
ils font honneur à la République
des problèmes des difficultés beaucoup
de Français en ont
mais la violence ne règle jamais rien
quand on appartient à notre communauté
nationale
on en respecte les règles
les enfants les adolescents ont besoin
de valeur de repères
l'autorité parentale et capitales
les familles doivent prendre toute leur
responsabilités
celles qui s'y refusent doit être
sanctionné comme la loi le prévoit
celle qui connaissent de grandes
difficultés
doivent en revanche être activement
soutenu
ce qui est en jeu
c'est le respect de la loi mais aussi la
réussite de notre politique
d'intégration
il faut être stricte dans l'application
des règles du regroupement familial
il faut renforcer la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière et les trafics
qu'elles génèrent
il faut intensifier l'action contre les
filières de travail clandestin cette
forme moderne de l'esclavage
mais l'adhésion à la loi et aux valeurs
de la République
passent nécessairement par la justice la
fraternité la générosité
c'est ce qui fait que l'on appartient à
une communauté nationale
c'est dans les mots et les regards
avec le cœur et dans les faits que ce
marque le respect auquel chacun a droit
et je veux dire aux enfants des
quartiers difficiles
quel que soit leur origine
qu'ils sont tous les filles et les fils
de la République
nous ne construirons rien de durable
sans le respect
nous ne construirons rien de durable si
nous laissons monter d'où qu'ils
viennent le racisme l'intolérance
l'injure notre âge
nous ne construirons rien de durable
sans combattre ce poison pour la société
que sont les discriminations
nous ne construirons rien de durable si
nous ne reconnaissons pas et n'assumons
pas la diversité de la société française
elle est inscrite dans notre histoire
c'est une richesse et c'est une force
chaque compatriote
le devoir de la République
c'est d'offrir partout et à chacun les
mêmes chances
grâce à l'école grâce au travail des
enseignants un nombre considérable de
jeunes
issus des quartiers difficiles
réussissent dans tous les domaines
mais certains territoires
cumulent trop de handicap trop de
difficultés
des territoires confrontés à la violence
et au trafic des territoires où le
chômage est massif et l'urbanisme
inhumain
des territoires ou des enfants sont
déscolarisés ou trop de jeunes peines à
trouver un emploi même lorsqu'ils ont
réussi leurs études
aux racines des événements que nous
venons de vivre il y a évidemment cette
situation
nous sommes à l'oeuvre pour y répondre
beaucoup a déjà été entrepris
urbaines pour ramener de l'emploi dans
les quartiers
le plan de rénovation urbaine pour
remplacer les bars et les tours par un
habitat plus humain
le Plan de Cohésion Sociale pour lever 1
à 1 les handicaps dont souffrent les
plus vulnérables
des mesures fortes pour permettre aux
familles surendettées de s'en sortir le
contrat d'accueil et d'intégration
la loi sur l'école entre en application
elle donnera à chaque élève les moyens
d'acquérir le socle des connaissances
indispensables et permettra de lutter
plus efficacement contre le fléau de
l'île lettrisme
et le gouvernement vient de prendre des
décisions nouvelles pour aider davantage
les personnes et les territoires qui ont
moins d'atouts que les autres
sachez que cette volonté politique
et cette engagement financier majeur de
la France
son sang
il commence à apporter des réponses aux
problèmes des quartiers difficiles
mais il s'agit nécessairement d'un
effort de longue haleine
cependant mes chers compatriotes
nous ne changerons pas les choses en
profondeur
sans l'engagement de chacun
sans une profonde évolution des esprits
nous appartenons à une grande nation
à son histoire mais aussi par les
principes sur lesquels elle est fondée
une nation qui rayonne dans le monde
et ce soir je veux dire aux françaises
et aux Français
et plus particulièrement au plus jeune
que par de la les doutes et les
difficultés que chacun peut connaître
nous devons tous être fiers d'appartenir
à une communauté qui a la volonté de
faire vivre les principes d'égalité et
de solidarité et qui fait pour cela des
efforts considérables
c'est une chance d'appartenir à la
Communauté française
chacun doit en avoir conscience et agir
en conséquence
mais je veux dire aussi à tous les
Français
que pour que ce modèle singulier
continue à vivre
pour qu'il garde toute sa force
nous ne pouvons transiger avec certains
principes
nous le savons bien les discriminations
sapent les fondements même de notre
République
une Haute autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations a été créé
ses pouvoirs sont considérables
puisqu’elle pourra désormais infliger
des sanctions
mais ne nous y trompons pas ce combat ne
pourrait être gagné que si chacune et
chacun d'entre nous s'y engage vraiment
et personnellement
les entreprises et les organisations
syndicales doivent se mobiliser aussi
sur la question essentielle de la
diversité et de l'emploi des jeunes
issus des quartiers en difficulté
qu'il n'est pas question
d'entrer dans la logique des quotas qui
montre en quelque sorte du doigt ceux
qui en bénéficient et qui est injuste
pour ceux qui n'y ont pas droit
il s'agit de donner aux jeunes les mêmes
chances face à l'emploi
combien de kurriculum vitae passent
encore à la corbeille en raison du nom
ou de l'adresse de la
je rencontrerai sur cette question les
représentants des partenaires sociaux
dans les prochains jours
pour mieux aider les jeunes notamment
les jeunes en difficulté
allez vers l'emploi
j'ai décidé de créer un service civil
volontaire
associant accompagnement
et formation
il concernera 50 000 jeunes en 2007
j'appelle aussi tous les représentants
des communes à respecter la loi qui leur
impose d'avoir 20% au moins de logements
sociaux
j'ai conscience des difficultés
mais on ne sortira pas de la situation
actuelle
si l'on ne met pas en cohérence les
discours et les actes
je rencontrerai également
l'ensemble des responsables de
l'audiovisuel
les médias doivent mieux refléter la
réalité française d'aujourd'hui
et j'invite les chefs des partis
politiques apprendre leur part de
responsabilité
les élus la représentation nationale
doivent eux aussi refléter la diversité
de la France
c'est une exigence pour faire vivre
notre démocratie
mes chers compatriotes
soyons lucides soyons courageux
sachant tirer toutes les leçons de cette
crise
chacun doit respecter les règles
chacun doit savoir que l'on ne viole pas
impunément la loi
mais sachons aussi nous rassembler pour
agir dans la fidélité au principe qui
font la France
la communauté nationale tout entière en
sortira meilleur et plus forte et vous
pouvez compter sur ma détermination vive
la république et vive la France
[Musique]